all right moment of honesty here I'm a
little bit embarrassed that it took me
this long to talk about an anime summer
wars as an animation junkie I do have a
certain love and appreciation of anime
however I don't call myself an anime
fanatic by any means because I think
anime is like any other art form there's
some good stuff there's some great stuff
there's a lot of junk some Wars
thankfully is not junk this movie just
blew me away when I first saw it and I
recently rewatched it because I was
lucky enough to get it as a Christmas
present and while I can't quite recreate
that first I'm watching it it's still
amazing and works on just about every
level for me so the movie opens
basically with a sort of an expository
bit describing oz which is basically
this mega social network I mean imagine
if absolutely everything was run through
Facebook companies use it for all their
internal stuff your finances your
security absolutely everything is run
through what is also a social networking
does games and does everything else that
gets established at the very opening and
then the set up from there is a high
school nerd who's a little bit awkward
with girls gets asked by a girl in his
class to join her and her family for a
few days over the summer break and I'm
gonna stop the description of the plot
right there because a big part of what I
loved about this movie especially the
first time that I watched it was really
not being able to see where was going in
all the stuff that was going to be
integrated into it cuz once you've seen
the film you'll be able to appreciate
what I'm about to say where it starts
and where it ends are two very different
places and there are places that I if
you had just told me oh it starts with
this ends with this I would have gone
what there's no way that that works and
but watching it go and what it goes
through and everything that gets
involved and integrated in the journey
that the film itself in the story goes
through as it changes and evolves and
new elements are at it in and new
information is broadened is just really
wondrous because you don't know what's
going to happen next you don't know
where it's going to go next so what's
the next thing next element next genre
that's going to be touched on in this
whole overall journey you know there's a
phrase
sometimes overused by reviewers and that
is this film has everything but I say
that here and I say with no hyperbole if
you love anime any kind of anime any
aspect of anime whatever it is that you
like about anime it is in this film
somewhere and more to the point it is
integrated perfectly seamlessly and
organically something that has as many
disparate elements as this thing has
should never work it should feel
cluttered it should feel rushed it
should feel like an absolute mess but it
just flows so perfectly I know almost
nothing about this movie going in and
I'm so grateful for that I watched it
solely on the strength of having really
enjoyed the girl who left through time
which is from the same director another
fantastic film that is definitely worth
seeking out I mean not only does this
film have a disparate amount of elements
and aspects and genres and touchdowns
but it's got a massive cast of
characters who this yeah that should be
wait that that many characters should
require a long-running anime series to
even feel like they have any aspect at
all they are completely one-dimensional
but these all feel really for legitimate
they feel lived in and that it just
speaks to the strength of the design the
pacing and also of the voice work the
dub on this is really phenomenal you do
not have to watch this with subtitles I
mean I don't know what else I can say
it's funny it's touching it's intense
it's intimate it's epic and now that
I've probably overhyped it and anyone
who actually sees the thing is gonna
watch it and go what is he talking about
I think I'm gonna step away while I'm
ahead so what is your personal all-time
favorite anime style animation film
whatever it is drop something down in
the comments and let's talk about as for
me I'll be back as soon as I can get my
next fix
you